this great big story was made possible
by wells fargo established 1852
re-established 2018.
this is a story about a dinner but not
just any dinner this is a dinner that
involves this kitchen with these cooks
and this garden with these gardeners
it's a dinner that's helping a community
fight homelessness in a big way
[Music]
san francisco has a large population of
homeless people
just last year over 4 000 homeless
people were reported unsheltered and
over 6 000 unemployed
enter farming hope a non-profit created
to help those in need by training them
in urban farming and cooking in the
hopes of helping them find full-time
employment
joining us from the farming hope
initiative is jamie
kevin
and aisha
we just wanted to be the organizers to
piece this knowledge together of how do
we grow food and cook it in a way that
opens up our food system that gets
people the job and the training that
they need and want so what we do is we
recruit folks who are experiencing
homelessness to join the farming hope
community and put our mission into
action
but for this to work participants have
to learn the true meaning of farm to
table
[Music]
so the first step is in the garden with
asia my role is to help facilitate the
employees in the garden so since we just
planted this one maybe we won't harvest
it but we can harvest from the rooftop
garden we water we're also growing new
plants so we're putting seeds in the
ground we harvest every week for the
kitchen kevin uses these in his tacos
and so being here and encouraging them
beautiful to
get back in touch with themselves just
as much as learning about gardening i
think is important
then once the produce is grown it's off
to the kitchen with kevin my role in the
kitchen is to facilitate a lot of the
hands-on training that we're doing with
our transitional homeless folks we do a
lot of stuff from knife basics time
management cleanliness stuff that can be
directly transferable to other jobs
either in food or not in food
i'm always really inspired by the people
that we're working with because they're
the ones that really dedicate themselves
to the work they're here they're putting
in 110
so i think our folks really deserve a
lot of the applause
and finally the team gets to enjoy the
fruits of their labor each week they
serve up a meal to both homeless and
non-homeless people so for tonight's
menu we started off with a roasted
butternut squash taco the second taco is
a stewed zucchini the last taco is a
fried rock fish taco and then lastly for
dessert we're serving a vegan chocolate
mousse and while for some eating is the
best part for philip it's the experience
i was homeless for
almost six months for the very first
time in my life i was introduced to
farmers hope so
i learned a whole lot can you smell it
it smells like lemons a little bit light
it kept me there thinking about my life
so when i'm there i have peace it gave
me a new place to go
i think the most unique part of farming
hope is
gathering people from distinct walks of
life to break bread together
and just be next to each other
not every moment of our life has to be
about fixing everything and it actually
has to start from that place of empathy
of awareness of neighborliness and by
involving everybody at the same level
and a dining table it allows us to open
the space up to
actual dialogue actual empathy actual
solutions
[Music]
you